hello everyone and welcome to the
infectious disease virtual event my name
is Cory Watson I'm an assistant
professor in the Department of
Biochemistry and like the genetics at
the University of Louisville School of
Medicine today I'm going to be talking
to you about some of our work in the in
big abbiamo side my talk is titled
overcoming complexity to elucidate the
role in the novel and polymorphism on
and the functional antibody response so
I'm gonna sort of deliver my slides
today in two parts really three so I'm
gonna give a brief introduction sort of
giving you some background on P cells
and antibodies mostly focusing on what
we know about the genetics of the genes
that encode antibodies and then I'm
going to move into two different but
related sections highlighting some of
the work that we are currently doing to
deal with some of the issues that face
the field with respect to interrogating
antibody genetic diversity so just a
little background most of us are
probably aware of the fact that their
b-cells are critical components of the
immune system and that they function in
many different processes importantly B
cells are the only cells that produce
antibodies proteins called antibodies
and anatoly's are going to be the focus
of our talk today in particular and for
those of you who aren't familiar with
antibodies are these are molecules that
are composed of two identical heavy
chains and two identical light chains as
shown by the blue and red symmetrical
bars here in the Oval on the right hand
side of the slide and these antibody
molecules are expressed by B cells
either on their cell surface or are
secreted and they have many different
functions in the immune system
and are involved in both innate and
adaptive immune responses and so today
we're going to be talking about
diversity and antibodies in particular
how this diversity arises and so sort of
dumb down or layman's perspective on
antibody diversity you can sort of boil
down this idea by thinking about the
world of pathogens that we face which
tends to be rather diverse and so our
immune systems have evolved diversity as
well via antibodies and so all of us
produce antibody repertoire is how they
call them they're also very diverse and
this diversity is meant to face the ever
diverse challenges that come across us
in our daily lives such as viruses and
bacteria and so forth and in fact our
bodies can produce a lot of antibodies
with different specificities and so an
underappreciated area or one at least
that many people haven't haven't
investigated in too much depth is this
idea that to have this diverse antibody
repertoire we need to start somewhere
and that starting place for at least
most mammals is the genome and and the
genomic regions that encode antibodies
tend to be very diverse in themselves
and so this is what the genomic region
that encodes genes that ultimately will
go on to generate an antibody I'll kind
of explain a little bit of this to you
because we'll see figures like this as
we go through the presentation and so
depicted here R is a region of
chromosome 14 in the human genome the
very end basically right next to the key
linear and in this region which is about
a mega base of length so about a million
base present length we have these little
green boxes these little blue boxes some
yellow boxes and then
additional blue boxes and so these all
form the precursors for the different
antibodies that we might generate in our
repertoire and specifically these gene
segments encode the heavy chain so the
two longer paired molecules here shown
in the left-hand side of the screen and
then similarly we have two additional
regions of the genome that encode the
light chain regions or the light chain
part of the expressed antibody and these
are termed IG lambda or IG kappa IG l +
IG k for short and then when an antibody
is being produced you'd either have
genes from the lambda locus or genes
from the capital Lukas being transcribed
and ultimately contributing to the
production of antibody and we all know
those of us who take in immunology
classes that there are fairly complex
mechanisms that ultimately lead to the
generation of an antibody and these
mechanisms many of them at least are
unique to b-cells and in some cases
t-cells and this generally happens the
we can take the heavy chain as an
example here which is kind of depicted
in a in a more simplified cartoon
version at the top we have a little
cluster of the gene segments or variable
gene segments we have a little cluster
of D gene segments or diversity genes
and a cluster of J gene segments also
called joining segments and these genes
are the the building blocks of the
variable portion of the antibody and so
when it b-cells developing the DNA and
that V cell from starting with just one
chromosome will ultimately rearrange to
take a single V gene a single DG miss
single chaging to put them into a VD j
recombination event which is shown here
with the red orange and dark red boxes
and so these will ultimately form a bdj
rearrangement which gets transcribed
from the genome and ultimately spliced
together with what
concept domain jeans and will go on to
make an antibody or have an antibody
translated from that mRNA transcript and
so it's the joining of these different
combinations of VG and J genes that
gives us our initial initial diversity
offer chart which we refer to as
combinatorial diversity in addition we
get junctional diversity which is the
addition or deletion of nucleotides when
the V and D and D and J genes get paired
together in the genome and ultimately
after antibodies have seen antigen or
stimulated additional mutations can be
introduced up to these molecules to give
them even even greater diversity and so
a lot of these mechanisms have been
studied in pretty good detail not as
much in human although that's changing
now but definitely in model organisms
but an underappreciated region which is
the area of focus for my group is this
idea that at the population level we
actually are learning that there's a lot
of genetic diversity among humans and we
actually have a very poor understanding
of how this diversity also contributes
to diversity that one might see and the
antibody repertoire of a given
individual and then how about in turn
might go on to influence that
individuals immediate response in
different context and so that's going to
be a lot of what I talk to you about
today as this is the focus of most of
the work that my group does and so
building on that idea it's been
appreciated for a number of years that
that there are lots of different alleles
among the gene segments and code
antibodies so this is an example of
heavy chain variable genes which we old
term I GHD genes so in human there are
around 50 some-odd genes that may or may
not show up an individual's expressed
repertoire these are shown along the
x-axis here and plotted on the y-axis
are the number of known alleles that
in 2012 for each of these genes so you
can see this is just meant to illustrate
diversity and you can see that for some
genes there's only a couple alleles
known in the human population and for
other genes there are upwards of 20
alleles known and so this this
illustrates that there's diversity but
there's a sort of a caveat here in that
we also know despite the fact that there
are many alleles curated and existing
databases that these databases are
actually quite incomplete and just to
sort of illustrate this it's now an
appearance since I initially made this
figure in 2012 that many new two genes
genes have been discovered an
interesting point from this is that most
of these novel alleles are novel
variants of and discovered have come
from non-caucasian samples and so this
is really illustrated to the community
of researchers in this space that
there's a lot of sampling that still
needs to be done if we're going to sort
of fully more fully catalog a wheel at
variation among the gene segments and IG
regions in addition to this allelic
variation we also know that the locus
itself is very complex and when I say
it's very complex
what I mean is that it looks unlike a
lot of other places in the genome I'll
try to explain this a little bit more
detail so this is the original cartoon I
showed you for the in your blog on heavy
chain Lucas you can see here again the
green boxes the blue boxes and the
yellow boxes indicating a different gene
segments and what I've shown you here
are functional gene segments so these
are gene segments that typically get
used in a repertoire but if we actually
look at the locus in more detail and we
include pseudogenes the locus looks
something like this
and in fact when you look at all
possible variable genes including those
that are deemed non-functional you see
that there's over a hundred genes in
this and this sort of relatively small
region of the genome and what this means
is that because these genes are all
phylogenetic related that a lot of the
locus is highly repetitive so there's a
lot of sequence that you
see over and over in the region and in
fact about well more than 50% of iph
falls within what we refer to as a
statement of duplication so a region of
sequence that is highly similar to
another piece of sequence and the locus
and adding additional complexity to this
we also know that copy number of
variants of gene copy number variants
are common look its meaning that we have
we know that in some people genes or
other scene and zero copies one copy to
copy three copies and so on and because
of this diversity this means that no one
single genome reference assembly
contains all the genes that one might
find in the human population and when
you sort of tally all this together the
fact that we don't know much about
allelic diversity in the population nor
do we have a good understanding of
haplotype diversity when this comes to
things like structural branch or copy
number variants like I'm showing here it
means that we don't actually know much
about half of type diversity in general
across the human population and because
of this lack of data it means that we've
also historically probably not done a
very good job of interrogating the ievo
side and this of course as one might
imagine has impacted lots of different
types of studies and continues to do so
today so we know that things like
disease Association studies like Gigi
wasps or genome-wide Association studies
have been impaired by this deficit of
theta and then this sort of feeds
through to the development of diagnostic
and therapeutic strategies as well as
understanding more basic molecular
mechanisms of how these genes are
regulated and so that presents us a
problem when one that we need to
overcome and so this is this is sort of
the first area that my life isn't
working on for for a number of years now
and and when one thinks about this
problem we have to kind of decide where
do we start in other words how do we
figure out what we know and don't know
and that's hard but we can take examples
from some other regions of the genome as
well so we have other regions like the
human leukocyte antigen Lucas or HLA we
have regions like those depicted here
for the the kir genes all of these
families are also quite complexed and
are comprised of multiple genes and so
in these other regions what you've seen
in the field are efforts to go back and
try to capture more haplotype variation
in other words sequence more complete
appetites but trying to get a basic
foundation of genomic resources for
these regions that can then be built on
with larger populations to go sequencing
and that's the basic model that we are
actually now following and so I'm going
to sort of give you some additional data
now that we've generated I'm some which
is published already it has been for a
number of years and give you an idea of
where this project is going and how
we're trying to remedy this problem and
so that leads us to part one which is
going to focus on how we're trying to
develop resources and tools to improve
reference assemblies and I Jebusite
every gain we're gonna focus mainly on
IgH here just for time but much of the
work we're doing also extends tekapo and
the low side as well and so it's a bit
old-school by by current terms but we're
using we're trying to leverage what are
referred to as large insert clone
libraries so these are referred to as
backs and our case backs or phosphate
clones and these are basically libraries
of DNA inserts so ecoli libraries of DNA
inserts in which the genomic the genomic
DNA from a given sample or individuals
been sheared randomly and then these
sort of fragments of the DNA then sub
cloned into vectors and then mortalized
and e-coli
and so we've been working with libraries
now both backs and
fatherhood's and these are these are
nice because each little chunk of DNA
that gets inserted into these vectors
can then be immortalized in an e.coli so
which you can then go back and isolate
DNA from and you'll get an isolated
piece of DNA from from that individuals
genome from a single chromosome that
individual genome and you can go back to
these clones and regions of interest
like I've shown here on the right and
you can actually take clones that
overlap each other and span a region of
interest and you can go back and
sequence this and so for complicated
regions some of this approach actually
makes the problem much easier so you can
actually resolve the load side more
easily than if you were say doing a
whole genome sequencing experiment and
so one of the first resources that we
use several years ago now was a complete
antenna for mole and so the power of
this library the details of what I had
to form or aren't so important except
that these cell lines that this cell in
particular has only a single chromosome
represented for each of all the human
chromosomes so for us we were interested
in 22 2 and 14 these these regions we
now know are haploid in this cell line
so that means we don't have to worry
about things like hetero zygosity when
it comes to assembling the low-side and
so we picked clones that spanned IgH and
muses library to resolve the first
complete haploid representation of the
ing low-side and in addition we
sequenced in a targeted way from
different many different individuals of
different ethnic groups Fossett's which
contain about 40 KB of sequence and we
would we would basically choose foz
modes from these individuals that we
thought looked as though they probably
contained copy number or structural
variants and so we sequenced about 30 of
these to try to resolve additional
haplotype variation in the locus and
this is just kind of a brief summary the
data detailed in this work are published
already
but I cannot give you a bite-sized view
so what we saw from this initial
sequencing were the presents and many of
these individuals of large structural
variants and the IG HV region so the
sizes of these different brands so when
I say shown to brands I mean big
deletions or insertions in the
chromosome that that included gene
segments and what the showed is
basically as was that for many of us
some of these genes will actually not be
present at all in our genomes for some
of those these genes will be president
multiple copies and it has alluded to
the fact that diversity and human
population is probably much greater than
we had anticipated and newer data coming
out is definitely supporting that vision
these data also revealed over 200 KB of
novel sequence that wasn't represented
at the time and the human reference
assembly they did dignified novel
sequences and alleles and so the
take-home is is that even from
sequencing from a relatively small
number of individuals we were able to go
back and start discovering a lot of
novel sequence in this region basically
highlighting the fact that that was
probably only the tip of the iceberg and
so a lot of the work we're doing now is
extending on this idea and then this is
to show you the power of these fosdick
lom's because you can sort of take byte
size 40 kV segments you can actually
resolve some very complex regions of the
locus and so this region is a quite
complicated part of the IgH locus in
which you have several gene segments
that can be copied up to four times in
one region and what we've seen so far is
of every individual we've we've sequence
a haplotype from it has a different
number of genes and a different sort of
assortment of these genes but the FA's
modes despite the fact that they are a
bit old-school and - so a high
throughput to offer a path towards
resolving some of this complexity and
what this initial screen allows us to do
in a very targeted way so I should go
back and ask
some broader population level questions
about specific structural grants in the
Lucas and so the I've highlighted here
three regions so there's a green a
purple and a red box here that are there
did noting three two structure brands
that we actually went in and asked a
population of about four hundred people
of samples from different parts of the
world
what allele frequencies of these
structure brands looked like and this is
shown here so you can see in all
instances these structure variants have
different frequencies of either the
insertion or deletion haplotypes
across human populations this was really
one of the first times that this had
been shown for the IOG regions at this
level and na has gone to show now that
that many of these variants are likely
going to be important for contributing
to antibody repertoire diversity and
potentially broader human phenotypes and
so this was an initial look at the Lucas
and now a lot of what we're doing is
trying to build on these ideas and do
much larger scale sequencing experiments
and so to begin this work we've again
are relying on these large historic
clones and so we're now sequencing
posits from this there's seven shown
here but we're actually sequencing eight
and until probably two to three thousand
clones from across the heavy and light
chain gene regions and that the intent
of this is to basically sequential bunch
of osment's and we using packed pile and
we take the FA's nodes we assemble them
and then we try to basically construct a
haplotype from each of these individual
libraries in most cases we're hoping to
to recover to have both types from each
individual as shown here so this is a
cartoon schematic of some of the
haplotype assemblies that we've
generated from one of the samples and
the idea is that ultimately will
recreate or reconstruct the IG low-side
from both chromosomes
of these surveyed individuals wish
because we're sequencing from positives
and using high depth of coverage of the
PacBio data we can produce very high
quality assemblies for this region which
can then go on to serve as a just
additional reference assemblies for
these low society human genome and
another critical aspect of this is that
we've tried to choose individuals from
different human populations so that the
reference assembly does a slightly
better job of representing the different
ethnic backgrounds that are often used
and disease genetic studies and so we
can we can start looking at some of
these sample types that we're
reconstructing and this is sort of an
initial pass of data that that we have
from six of these individuals and so we
started stitching the Fallas together we
can sort of reconstruct haplotypes here
I boil those down to again just looking
at the B segments in the region so these
these aren't positioned by scale but
just giving you an idea of allelic
variation and structural variation so
you can see among these six genomes
compared to the two reference assemblies
on the very bottom when you look at the
little boxes which are known in the B
genes these are color coded based on
what allelic variant we've found so
either known allelic variant which I
could note it as the star and then the
the numeric other one two three so on or
we have novel or genes that were still
processing in other words trying to get
solid assemblies before we think
although fuels but the take-home here is
that when you look at the segments
across individuals effectively what you
see is that there are a number of genes
in which you see the same allele call it
each time but there are many many genes
in which that's not the case and which
just in these these few have all types
we see lots of diversity in addition you
see differences in the number of genes
president each haplotype due to large
insertions and deletions that we've
discovered of new samples and so this
highlights that even in this small
sample of individuals are already seeing
that there's a
diversity which hints that the the need
to do a better job of characterizing
this of the human I mean if this using
at the population level and so then we
can do we can do a deeper dive more and
look things like snips across the region
so in addition to looking at the V
segment haplotypes we can also look at
variants that we see across the whole
locus so this is just looking at three
individuals a representative from the
Asian African and European populations
and all this figure really shows is the
overlap between snips and so in total
among these three individuals we find
about 4000 snips which is actually a lot
for an honorary KB region of the genome
particularly in only three individuals
what you can see is that most of these
samples have particularly African and
European samples have a high number of
snips that aren't seen in me and the
other samples fanship this is a small
end but this is just to sort of
highlight the strength of these data and
then one thing that was actually quite
surprising to us because because several
these samples had already been sequenced
from other projects including the
thousand genomes project it was a little
bit surprising that when we went in to
look at snips in these samples that we
found that a pretty significant portion
of them had never been a catalogue
before so we're expecting that once we
have completed our sequencing that
there's gonna be a lot of novel
variation of the the snip level as well
which can obviously then be integrated
into you know there in databases and
whatnot and so a little biology this
already coming out of these data it
seems clear that IgH probably is a
unique region of the genome in terms of
diversity as well so if we are to look
at the number of snips that we see in
the region and we compare those to other
parts of genome in this case we're
comparing us to all the snips seen in
each of these samples along chromosome
14 we see that the density of snip C&I
ghs much higher than that seen elsewhere
on chromosome 14
in this case it's about threefold higher
in these samples and and can be even
higher depending on which which region
of the locus you look at and if you look
at this density plotted along the locus
which I've done here
so you can see the base pair position of
IgH along the x-axis and the number of
snips per 10 KB windows you can see as
you sort of slide along the ith locus
that some some regions are actually much
more stiff dense than others and in all
of our sequencing that we're doing now
at a broader scale we're seeing this
trend over and over again and so this is
this is highlighting that there's likely
some interesting genomic dynamics going
on in this region okay so that that's a
that sort of a 30,000 foot view of some
of the approaches we're doing that are
meant to improve the genomic reference
resources that are available to the
community the other aspect that we that
I want to talk to you about today is how
we're building on these resources to try
to develop better genotyping tools and
so historically because of the
complexity of the idea regions these
have been very difficult to interrogate
using standard IEEE throughput methods
like Illumina Shortridge sequencing or
microarray technologies and so because
of that they are there's a need for more
specific sequencing strategies and
analysis tools in order to more fully
characterize a genomic variation in
these regions and of course the reason
that we're interested in doing this is
because we want to understand more
comprehensively the extent of variation
of human population but we also want to
try to understand how this Jagr
variation might contribute to variation
we see an antibody repertoire as well as
related human phenotypes and so this
next part I'm going to sort of go
through some of the data that we've been
generating to show you the strengths of
the tools we're working on as well as
give you some initial biological insight
into how effects are achieved our
Institute
tribute to antibody repertoire variation
and so we're generally following a model
that we've put forward in that that
journal and appetite variation can
contribute to variation that one sees in
an individual's Express repertoire and
that this has additional downstream
correlates to other types of functional
data that may or may not be important
for informing things like clinical care
or personalized treatments or may in
fact be predictive of an individual's
susceptibility to a given disease and so
the sort of barrier in this model
historically has been the ability to
interrogate the germline haplotype and
so what I'm gonna be showing you in the
next several slides is is our attempts
to sort of develop tools that overcome
this and so there's precedent for
thinking that that the germline may
affect contribute to the antibody
response and this has sort of been
highlighted as people will begin using
this new relatively new technology
called antibody repertoire sequencing
which allows you using next-gen
sequencing to essentially screen either
the genomic really DJ rearrangements or
DJ rearrangements expressed and an RNA
sample to capture the diversity that's
seen at within an individual's expressed
into by groundbirch or and this method
is is becoming quite pervasive now and
it's telling us all sorts of things
about the function of B cells and how if
the values contribute to the immune
response and one of the things that we
learn sort of a basic level is we using
this approach we can we can start
understanding how often particular genes
with n in this case the IgH locus get
used in their individuals repertoire and
this can then be applied to many Sam
and we can we can try to see which jeans
might be most important for particular
responses or how variable individual
repertoires are compared to another
person's in the population and so this
is sort of a small snapshot of what
these data might look like so this is
showing you the frequency of each of the
V gene is noted on knee x axis as it
appears an individual's repertoire in
this case we're looking at two Mazda
guide twin pairs a and B which are
denoted by the different colored bars so
you can see some genes are used
relatively really low levels and the
repertoire and some genes are used at
higher levels and this is this has been
sort of shown over and over as people
done more and more sequencing like this
what some of these early studies show
this one in particular by jay Glanville
in 2011 was that one notable finding is
that the frequencies at which genes are
used actually are more tightly
correlated and models like ike twins
than compared to unrelated individuals
and what this told us at the time was
that there is actually probably a
genetic correlate or underpinning for
repertoire diversity this had sort of
been appreciated several decades ago but
hadn't really been looked at this
comprehensively and so this was a big
motivator for the work that we do
because it suggests that in fact
variation within the immunoglobulin
regions Janak variation could be
contributing to to this particular
feature and that in that there is higher
concordance and Mazda guide twin
repertoire is compared to other related
people and in fact in a target a study
that we worked on we wanted to look at a
particular region that encodes the gene
IG HP 169 which is known to have many
different allelic forms but mainly two
forms that either encode
a finale in apposition 54 or loosing it
position fit before and this jeans also
known to variant copy numbers so some
individuals were carry two copies in
their genome and other individuals may
carry three or four and we wanted to ask
quite simply can we ask a this very this
genetic variation and see if that
contributes to the different types of
the 169 antibodies that we observe at
repertoire and in fact when we did this
we saw that both the copy number variant
and the allelic coding variant
correlated with the usage of that gene
and an individual 90 preparatory and so
these to try to show that so the top one
looks at the copy number variant so
individuals that have either 0 1 2 3 or
4 copies of the f-type allele of 169
have varying levels of expression so
those are the 0 have the lowest and
those with 4 copies have the highest
expression similarly we saw that
individuals who have who are homozygous
for the leucine leucine variant have the
lowest expression of V 169 and those
with phenylalanine homozygous for the
phenomena barian have the highest
expression of P 169 and so this this
gives credence to the monozygotic join
study which has also been replicated I
should say a couple times now in that
it's actually showing that some of the
variation generation that may be
contributing to this to the heritability
of repertoires is probably going to be
located and IU Mohsen themselves and so
this was just a targeted targeted
variant or targeted study looking at a
single variant but as I told you several
sites before we know that there are
thousands and thousands of genetic
variants and IgH locus and so we needed
a way to to do this more comprehensively
but still in a high throughput manner oh
and I should say that in addition to
showing these features we also looked at
these particular variants and different
human populations and we saw that there
was a pretty extensive variation between
different ethnic groups so we observed
that with respect to the gene copy
number variant and the coding variant
that there were different frequencies
depending on what your ethnic background
was and so on the left here you can see
that copy number variation tends to be
higher in African samples and lower and
Asian samples and similarly the F
alleles are at much higher prevalence
and African samples compared to the
individuals of South Asian populations
and so what this highlighted was that
you know if there's any functional
features associated with this gene that
that there may be variation in the
phenotype level depending on what your
ethnic background is and so as I said we
needed to come up with ways to do this
in a more high-throughput fashion and so
we started several years ago developing
an approach to target IgH so in other
words trying to specifically pull down
DNA fragments from a given sample for
the ith locus and sequence these using
PacBio and we wanted to use backbone
because we wanted to leverage the long
reach sequencing the tactile offers
because we knew that standard approaches
using say Illumina sequencing or short
reads intended to be a very problematic
for the IG locus primarily due to the
complexity and the lack of more complete
resources and so this is just a general
cartoon of how this work she essentially
designed targets all ago targets to your
region of interest in this case
IgH and you pull down those DNA
fragments and you so I select them to a5
a KB and in size range and then you
essentially take those enriched
fragments and you you make a sequencing
library and effectively once we do this
we can then sequence it on the back bio
and use those data to try to reconstruct
haplotypes for IgH and collagen egg
variation and of course the the
advantages to this approach
or that it's relatively high throughput
compared to WGS and and West less
expensive and whole genome sequencing
and in comparison to other strategies
that currently exist the long reads give
us a better ability to actually resolve
complex parts of the HTH Lucas in
addition to this bench meant that we've
also been developing bioinformatics
tools to deal with these data and these
these effectively allow us to take the
reads map them to the locus and try to
phase snips and phase the reads
accordingly and then reconstruct to
haplotypes across the region which then
can be annotated and snips and gene
variants and copy number variants
etcetera it can be called from these
data just an example or region in which
we can do this so you can see for these
three samples we have three diploid
samples one two three and a single
haploid sample and you can see there's a
presence of multiple snips in these
samples in this region shown by the
little blue and green ticks and we can
use these these read these snips within
the reads to partition blue and green
reads here into two different haplotypes
and then we can do assemblies this
approach ultimately allows us to do
things like V gene Apple typing a Kindle
what I've shown you some of the other
figures and the previous slides so in
other words this offers a
high-throughput way to sort of do some
of the Apple typing based sequencing and
then we can we can take information on
no comedy number grants or structural
grants and we can use that information
to effectively integrate different
methods to call those structural grant
genotypes and a sample and then
extrapolate this out to the population
level so for this this particular
insertion deletion brand which involves
about 60 KB of sequence we can do things
like assess read depth and conduct local
assemblies and make sniff calls and then
ultimately generate
as few genotypes for that that we're
taking their event across samples that's
all something that's been be quite
challenging to do until now using
genomic approaches and so what we're
currently doing now is because we
ultimately understand how this variation
contributes to being responsible we're
conducting some of the first studies
trying to do just that so we want to
genotype a bunch of people using this
approach and then look in their Express
antibody repertoire is to see if we can
associate some of the chart line
variants with variation that we see at
repertoire so we've done this now in
about 50 healthy adults and this is the
general model so it's just following a
general eqtl model or expressing
quantitative trait locus model in which
you can essentially take genotypes or
haplotype information from a sample and
you can ask does that sample or does
that excuse me those genotype contribute
to the observed usage of a given B
segment and the repertoire so this is
these are a couple hypothetical examples
shown on the right here and these box
plots so you can see for the V gene one
we're asking do things like gene
deletions for example contribute to the
expression of the gene repertoire or do
for example other regulatory variants
contribute to the expression of the
genes and the data set we have we we
have sequenced all 50 of these samples
using our protocol and in total have
generated almost a sort of high-quality
call set of about 6,000 snips CMV
calling is still in progress and we can
then take repertoire data of IG and
repertoire data from these individuals
on which we have usage metrics for about
57
hhb genes and then we can essentially
ask for those associations between Jagr
variants and gene expression and what we
see when we do this in fact is that
there are lots of associations and so
here this this chart
chose for all of these segments that we
have reliable data on the top most
associated snip statistically speaking
with the usage of that gene and so shown
on the x-axis here is minus log 10
p-value and on the y are all the gene
segments that we've that we've assayed
you can see here that for many of them
if you use sort of a nominal p-value
cutoff for many of them there is a
significant at least one since that is
significantly associated with this
expression so in this case in this data
set there are 39 out of 57 genes that we
screen have at least one snip that's
associated with its usage and then for
many of these we can be sorted to get
internal validation within this data set
because we see clusters of snips that
are associated with a given gene so in
this case again the the genes are shown
on the y axis and instead on the x axis
this time we have the number of snips
that are associated with each gene with
the expression of each gene at the
cutoff of minus log 10 equal to 4 and
you can see for many of these genes that
there's over 100 snips that will
associated with with its usage so
showing that in fact that there
definitely are genetic correlates with
in the Asian regions so I'm going to
show you a couple of these just to sort
of illustrate that that they already are
highlighting the fact that they're
probably different sort of regulatory
mechanisms underlying vdj recombination
evolving these genes and so this is a
relatively straightforward one so this
is just a single sort of cluster of
snips as you can see in this Manhattan
plot on the left so this is basically
showing the IgH locus from left to right
and its position along Long chromosome
14 each of the dots shown are a p-value
for associated snip and its association
to the expression of igh before 61 and
so all the black dots
or genes in which or assuming our snips
that did not have a significant p-value
and all the salmon colored dots or pink
dots are snips that did have a nominally
significant association with with usage
at 461 and what I've done is highlight
in red circle there the the top
associated snip for 461 and that is
shown as a box plot over here so you can
get an idea of what the usage frequency
looks like let's each genotype given
that we only have 50 subjects there's
only one individual is a titi Amazigh
goat but you can see that the trend is
is quite clear and that CC Amazigh goats
out of much lower expression of 461
compared to the heterozygotes and almond
seconds but the relatively simple one we
have this a single cluster of snips
correlating with just a single gene then
we have we see some other and some other
interesting patterns so this is a really
highly significant effect and so this
one we initially noted for the gene IG
HP 3-9 as you can see there's a pretty
tall peak there of associate snips but
when we look closer this we actually saw
that this snip also correlated with the
expression of multiple genes
aside from 3-9 and when you go back and
you look more the region it's clear that
this snip is likely tagging a known
structural grant appetite so we know
that already that individuals on their
chromosomes can either carry a haplotype
that includes the gene 3-9 and 1-8 or
they can include Apple type that has the
genes 5 - 10 - 1 or 364 - d and in fact
what you see here is that this snip
correlates with genes in such a way that
their embrace effects depending on which
haplotype is clearly being tagged by the
snip some individuals who are cc have
low expression of 3 - 9 but have higher
expression of 3 60 40 and 5 - 10 - 1 for
example so that's just obviously a
structure gradient that's that's leading
to this effect
and then we're also interested in going
back and looking at the gene I mentioned
before the 169 because we we had
previously shown that there is an effect
of genetic variation and this gene and
this gene is also known to have an
important role in the development of
probably HIV antibodies for influenza
and so we went back and looked at this
one and in fact again we do we do indeed
see very strong genetic effects for 160
on expression in this case the clusters
is quite large and complex and also
includes a large structural brain which
which we already knew about for 169 an
interesting thing about this is that
this snip also has inverse effects on
other genes and the locusts assigned for
169 so again you see something so much
what we showed at the previous line in
which GG homozygotes may have lo 169
expression but they have a higher
expression of 366 and 459 the mechanisms
that there are underlying this are
currently unknown but I think these data
are going to help us start getting at
some of these questions so I'm
interesting known about that particular
step is that it does it does reside
within a CTE CF and DNA's one signal
from the encode data sets ctcf in
particular is has been shown to be
involved in vdj recombination so that
might be a good candidate regulatory
mechanism for this particular effect and
so with that I'm going to leave you at
the conclusion slide so I hope today
that the data we've we've we've
discussed give you the bat a combat the
IG Llosa extremely complex at the
genomic level and also highly
polymorphic and that this has several
consequences for how we think about the
role of IG variation B cell function
antibody function and ultimately disease
and that this sort of lack of knowledge
highlights a need for improved genomic
resources
so that we can begin developing better
methods for interrogating genetic
variation at IgH Lucas I also hope that
you are walking away from this dog
feeling convinced that indeed the IG low
so I probably do contribute to to
variation we see an antibody response
than that that that there are likely
roles for IQ variation and probably
important clinical phenotypes not to
mention that that doing these types of
analyses are probably going to be key
first steps and trying to understand the
molecular mechanisms that that influence
vdj recombination at least in humans and
for us you know the plans are to keep
extending this work and start applying
our approaches to larger cohorts
including those that included to see
individuals with disease or different
clinical phenotypes of interest and
these will also be able to move into
animal models so that we can better
assess the different molecular
mechanisms that play for vdj
recombination repertory development and
so in that a lots of people to
acknowledge this has been a pretty big
effort and continues to be from from
different groups so my group at the
University of Louisville primarily
William Gibson has been leading a lot of
the FA's mmit and capture work on the
bench side and then announced on a we
have Oscar Rodriguez has been doing most
of the computation of development and
Melissa Lynn Smith and not SIA the
assistant director of the tech deaf
Court there has been doing all the
sequencing for this project was a huge
undertaking an ally this year who
mentors Oscar on the computational
development and then definitely to wane
morasco and the Dana Farber who has been
working with me on many of these ideas
for many years whose sandals were used
for the initial eqtl study and with that
I will thank you for your attention
please feel free to send any
questions on my talk and I will get back
to you via email thanks and have a good
one